where do you think
as president or as a politician
is the most impact to be had i've been
reading a lot about hitler recently
and one of the things that i'm more and
more i'm starting to wonder
what the hell did he do alone in a room
with a
one-on-one with people because it seems
like that's where he was exceptionally
effective
when i when i think about certain
leaders
i'm not sure stalin was this way i
apologize been very obsessed with
this period of human history uh it just
seems like
certain leaders are extremely effective
one-on-one
a lot of people think of hitler even in
lincoln
as a speech maker as a great charismatic
speech maker
but it seems like to me that some of
these guys were
really effective inside a room and what
do you think
what's more important your effectiveness
to uh
to make a hell of a good speech sort of
being
in a room with many people or is it all
boiled down to one-on-one
well i think in a sense it's both one
needs to do both and most
politicians most leaders are better at
one or the other it's the rare leader
who can do
both i will say that if you are going to
be
a figure who's a president or the leader
of a complex organization not a startup
but a complex organization where you
have many different constituencies and
many different interests
uh you have to do the one-on-one really
well because a lot of what's going to
happen
is you're going to be meeting with
people who represent different groups
right the
leader of the labor union the leader of
your investing board etc
and you have to be able to persuade them
and it's the intangibles that often
matter most
lincoln's skill and it's the same that
fdr had um
is the ability to tell a story i think
hitler was a little different uh but
i'm what i've read of stalin is he was a
storyteller too one-on-one storytelling
yeah that's my understanding is that he
he uh and what lincoln did i don't want
to compare lincoln to stalin what
lincoln did
uh is he he was not confrontational
uh he was happy to have an argument if
an argument were to be had but actually
what he would try to do is move you
through telling a story
that got you to think about your
position in a different way to basically
disarm you
and frankly roosevelt did the same thing
ronald reagan did the same thing
storytelling
is a very important skill it's almost
heartbreaking that
we don't get to have or maybe you can
correct me
if i'm wrong on this but it feels like
we don't have a lot of information how
all of these folks were
in private one-on-one conversations
even if we get like stories about it
it's like again sorry to bring up hitler
but
like uh people have talked about his uh
piercing gays when they're one-on-one
like there's a feeling like he's just
looking through you
i wonder like it makes me wonder it was
lincoln somebody who's a little bit more
passive
like who's more the ego doesn't shine
it's not like an overwhelming thing or
is it more like um
again i don't want to bring up
controversial figures but uh donald
trump where it's more
menacing right there's a more like
physically menacing thing where it's
almost like a
almost like a bullying kind of uh uh
dynamic so i wonder
you know i wish i wish we knew i wish
because
from a psychological perspective i
wonder if there's a thread that connects
most great leaders great question um so
i think the best
writer on this is max weber right and he
talks about the
the power of charisma the term charisma
comes from weber right and
weber's use of it actually to talk about
prophets and i think he has a point
right
uh leaders who are effective in the way
you describe
are leaders who feel prophetic or weber
says they have a kind of magic about
them
and i think that can come from different
sources i think that can come
that can come from the way someone
carries themselves it can come from the
way they use words
um so maybe there are different kinds of
magic that that that someone develops
but i think there
are two things that that seem to be
absolutely necessary first is you have
to be someone who sizes up the person on
the other side of the table
you cannot be the person who just comes
in and reads your brief
and then second i think it's interactive
and there is a quickness of thought so
you brought up donald trump i don't
think donald trump is a deep thinker at
all
but he's quick and i think that
quickness
is part of it's different from from
delivering a lecture where it's the
depth of your thought can you for 45
minutes analyze something
many people can't do that but they still
might be very effective
if they're able to quickly react size up
the person on the other side of the
table and react in a way that moves that
person in the way they want to move them
yeah and there's also just the coupled
with the quickness as a kind of
instinct about human nature yes sort of
asking the question
what does this person worry about what
is it what are the biggest problems
somebody uh
what is this steven schwartzman i think
said to me he's this businessman
i i think he said like what i've always
tried to do
is try to figure out like ask enough
questions to figure out what is the
biggest
problem in this person's life try to get
a sense of what is the biggest problem
in their life because that's actually
what they care about most
and most people don't care enough to
find out and so
he kind of wants to sneak up on that
right
and and find that and then use that
to then build closeness in order to then
probably he doesn't put in those words
but to manipulate the person into
whatever
to do whatever the heck they want and i
think
i i think part of it uh part of it is
that and part of
the effectiveness donald trump has is
how quick he's able
to figure that out
you